energy secretary hazel o'leary on
environmental grants
[Music]
now a forum on inner city children and
their legal representation
several attorneys joined in this
discussion with lee allen jones a former
resident of the chicago housing
developments and a youth reporter for
national public radio
the panel was held as part of children's
day during the american bar
association's annual meeting
the discussions an hour and 20 minutes
ellie create a continuing legal
education credit if you're from
pennsylvania or texas you need a special
form those forms are
on the table outside the room um and
otherwise for many of the other states
who sort of do it in a communal way
you can sign the book you don't have to
remove a page from the book to get cle
credit you simply need to make sure that
you've indicated your attendance of the
program in the book to get appropriate
cle credit in your home state
and that is all that information is on
the table outside the room
welcome to stories from the trenches
this is a program that's part of
children's day developed and
co-sponsored by the aba commission on
homelessness and poverty
the section on litigation and the
judicial administration division
each of these entities is committed to
and involved in efforts to link lawyers
with children who need assistance
information on their work
and the names of their staff
and volunteers are available in the
resource area outside the room
that's where you'll find your cle
materials as well
in particular i want to point out janet
chaplin
frank cervone uh margie gualtieri
um from the litigation section and nancy
anderson and pat hanrahan from the
commission on homeless and poverty
nancy and pat are here
these staff have helped
to make stories from the trenches
possible and they are all here and eager
to help you
um to create your own stories to make a
difference in the lives of children
my name is clinton devoe i'm a municipal
court judge in atlanta
i hear criminal domestic and family
violence cases exclusively
this program is about
what makes life difficult for many of
america's children
about the circumstances that bring
couples and families into my court
and into the many courts in your
communities
but today
we're going to talk about more than the
facts on the ground
we lawyers are doing and can do
much about these facts and the lives of
america's children
our children
for their cooperation and support and
making this program possible the
steering committee is grateful
to the litigation section the initial
administration division the commission
on homelessness and poverty
and the standing committee on lawyers
public service and the center for pro
bono
we're also very grateful to the
panelists for participating and to
c-span for taping this program for
broadcast
now let me briefly introduce our
speakers and tell you we'll give you a
few more bits of detail
first
lee allen jones
leon is 17 he's from chicago he's been a
national public radio commentator for
four years
during those four years he's given us an
inside view on the lives and concerns of
children in chicago that i think really
accurately reflect
the issues that face children in urban
areas around the country there's a cd
available i've gotten my copy he only
brought about 15 sorry that means only
14 of you can get the other copy i've
got mine you'll have to get yours
lee allen is a senior at martin luther
king jr high school in chicago and he is
the junior spokesperson for the note
dope express
faith samples
she did her undergraduate work at howard
university in washington dc
she earned her master's and phd degrees
in program evaluation and planning from
cornell university in new york
dr samples has worked as a teacher
a counselor and a program evaluator she
has currently research director at the
national center for children in poverty
at columbia university
she is completing an evaluation of
violence prevention programs in 15 new
york city elementary schools and she
will tell us about her work and what she
sees and what children see and feel in
the schools where she is currently
working
attorney jack london is a partner in the
san francisco law firm of morrison and
foster
he is a graduate of harvard college and
yale law school although mr london's
private practice is largely focused on
corporate anti-trust and commercial
litigation
he has been and is a leader in lawyer
pro bono services and in legal services
he's a member of the bar of
arizona as well as of california and has
received numerous awards for his public
service work
susan cockfield is a new york university
law school route to began her legal
career as a new york university law
school root children scholar a public
service fellowship
she has
been active with lawyers for children
and her particular focus is on
representing children
in foster care
she's in private practice with the firm
of davis scott weber and edward edwards
she started in the new york office and
now works in their miami office
she's particularly
active in guardian ad litem programs in
florida and as i mentioned focuses on
representing children
in foster care
we're going to
simply
have each of the speakers go in the
order as i've introduced them and then
we hope that you will engage in a
conversation about the work that they
are doing
and the work that you're doing
to bring
your resources and your skills
to help change the stories and the
trenches for children in america liam
thank you good morning
i'd like to give thanks to
the american bar association for
bringing me here
especially mrs pat hanrahan uh mr frank
cervone and all the others who
made this an enjoyable stay
my grandfather for accompanying me here
this weekend
first i'd like to talk about my
experiences as far as
what i can give to this
this speak
about wearing the trenches i probably
have a
a lot of
to tell you but i only have a short
period of time to talk as i have to
respect other panelists
i'm from the south side of chicago
i live
surrounded by
as you call uh
sub housing a lot of projects that we
call them
around a lot of gangs right now
and my around my in my
now my community there's a gang warfare
going on right now
about
about a block between both gangs is
where i am at uh they they try to call
the street there's only one street to
divide both gas one another and really
it's not uh two different gangs it's the
same gang but they're having a strife
between one another
and
a lot of people got shot i remember not
just last week
i was coming from football practice
and i went to a friend's house lloyd
newman who i uh did my documentaries
with and uh
someone that just got shot
homicide detectives running all around
now
some kids
that would hurt a lot of kids if they
were
weren't familiar to the surroundings and
things that go on
in the community that i'm in but kids
are now accustomed
to what goes on in that community and
that's scary with the simple fact that
they must harden themselves inside far
as a hard
fire them i mean that mentality they
must
you know have to i mean imagine yourself
at
a young age 11 10 having to block out
seeing someone laying on the pavement
bloody and getting shot you might have
to block that out just to just to you
know go on every day
and
that's that's scary that they have to
see that but yet we still
as a
people want them to succeed in those
conditions
and
if you look at the suburban atmosphere i
mean a lot of kids might have problems
at home for as a
divorce or just domestic disputes but
these kids deal with things like this on
a daily violence firsthand
so
if you
if your violence is in your home
it's in your community
it's in your surroundings i don't care
how many programs they put in your
school
but you're only in school for maybe five
six hours a day now that leaves 19 other
hours for you to see this and that i
mean if that's what you see every day on
a daily basis you think that's life
and a lot of kids have opportunities to
see other things like i'm saying this
weekend at disney world they might see
the commercials and you know see mickey
and donald duck running around but their
reality
is what they see every day and that's
shooting
gang banging uh drug dealing uh
prostitution in some cases
uh i mean and it's right in their home
some of their parents do it uh uncles
aunts i mean
and if you
are a young kid i mean
you you want to go to school i mean they
say go to going to school and you know
be the best you can be and all that but
how can you be the best you can be out
of those terrible situations
i can say that
i've uh
at a young age i was exposed to a lot of
those things i even debated with myself
either i want to take another route and
be and try to find something to do
positive or should i just go ahead and
submit
and be with the crowd and i mean i
graduated out of eighth grade with a
class about 75 kids only about 15 to 20
of them are still going to school on a
regular basis
uh you know most of them have kids now
some of them already been in jail
and
you know the
reform they they're i mean they're
talking about building more jails and
prisons but
if you look at
that you know the next three elections
the next four next 12 years
if you're locking up the young people
that will be voting these elections i
mean what can they contribute to society
if they're locked up
at you know 13 14 15 what can they
contribute to society when they make 21
20-23
i mean honestly what can they contribute
jail right now would be the worst thing
for any young person when you're going
there you're exposed to more things
than you're on the streets but that's
slowly changing every day
because i mean if you live in a
community such as mine
i'm not bragging on the situation
because it's nothing to brag about it's
terrible
um
it's almost that it's almost a a ritual
for you to go to jail and if you don't
go to jail then it's almost like you
don't have you haven't lived your life
and you haven't fulfilled the dream
and i mean my
dr milo the king's dream was far from
that
and i think now in 1996 uh going into
the next millennium
we as a people not black not white not
yellow not green
uh we need to you know put all that
aside and we need to focus because if we
don't look you know help our kids out
now you know
you know you get older every day
before you know it some of you guys are
being senior citizens that might scare
you
but
how this country be ran if
there if the youth of tomorrow
are locked up i mean
look at it i mean
what what would society be like
and part of that is lack of education in
most of these communities where there's
high crime
uh
the the schools are subpar i mean the
books that you might read in
a suburb suburban area or upscale area
the books are uh more updated the books
we read are still dealing with vietnam
and
and uh other warfares i mean those dates
output you know teaching methods have
been updated since those books were have
came out and a lot of schools are in uh
what you call that reform uh
they're i mean they're the schools
uh tesco is so low like the standardized
testing test that they take every year
the score is so low in some of these
schools like my high school is in that
same state and my grammar school that i
graduated from is in that same state
where their
scores on the standardized testing is so
low that they're bringing in state
my high school
has the lowest
lowest scores
in the whole state of illinois
the lowest scores but yet i'm a i go to
that school every day and it's not
because
the students don't want it is that
there's no one really there to bring it
out of them out of all this violence
things that they see every day i mean
school is the farthest thing away from
their mind and
you know if you have to worry about
living
every day then school is you know
secondary
to your everyday needs i mean uh then
you have then you might need necessary
funds to take care of yourself or a
sibling or an honor or uncle so
therefore school is probably secondary
and you how can you blame a person for
making school secondary when they have
to put their life first
you know
politicians every every turn they're
talking about how they want to do things
and make promises and make big
statements and
like the
gop that you know crime bills and all
this i mean
that's great to get you know have
congress talk about it but they're not
going to do anything then don't raise
the issue
i mean and yet these kids are they're
giving these kids jail cells at 18 and
19 yet they don't put out there that you
need to vote they don't have you know
they don't get you out there to register
to vote if they had a voting officer
every police car down i think we'd have
a a lot of people voting
uh when it comes around election time
but that's scary because if you get
educated voters out there then a lot of
people wouldn't be in office and that
scares a lot of politicians
and
i'm going to talk about solutions i've
gave a lot of there's been a lot of
statements about what's going on and it
would be wrong for me to talk about a
lot of the problems and not give a
solution to those problems
my solution would be that when tears do
committee crime or do make some kind of
mistake
we can't just say well we're gonna you
know it's no more hope because once you
give up on hope
there's nothing else to hold on to
and
that's the only thing we have right now
is hope and we have and we don't have a
lot of it going around nowadays i can
look at uh
i go back to my hotel i can look at the
know the local news and you know see if
there's not a lot of hope
uh so therefore
we have to give hope to these kids we
have to make them feel
self-pride you know make them feel good
about themselves i know maybe three or
four years ago i didn't feel very good
about myself i didn't know where what
was my direction like but now in 1996 i
have a lot of direction i have my own cd
i produced two documentaries for radio
i've produced uh
uh a tv documentary for abc news i've
traveled
uh and i'd say those experiences uh
changed me
and all because a person instilled
something in me and that's the note of
express foundation which i'm a junior
spokesperson for uh
they
in grammar school in the great i was a i
talked a lot but i didn't talk the way i
do now i had a lot of more
uh
bad words to say and not a lot of no
i was one of the kids i'm talking about
now but someone saw something to me
that they brought out of me and with
that you see me now in 1996 talking to
you about war in the trenches which i'm
not a part of but i'm trying to find
solutions for
so we need to get more
programs out there such as the
organization i'm in or the aba for
instance you
everybody in the av is successful they
wouldn't be in the aba
and i mean
um
you know a few years ago i laughed just
now that i didn't even know what the
american bar association was i thought
it was a bunch of alcoholics that were
promoting the habit
and
and now i'm speaking so i mean we have
to we have to really go at this at a
at a joint effort i mean aviation no
dope uh you know whoever to stop this
because
we have to we have to start we have to
start now you know it can't it's no
tomorrow if we don't prepare today so
i'm gonna sit back and let me just
sample speak and uh thank you
[Applause]
good morning i think uh the allen has
set the stage very well for what i want
to talk about today i'm a researcher by
training and i don't really want to get
stuck in the details and be
really dry statistics of um
what it means to conduct a study and
talk about the analysis of the data but
let me give you a little bit of
background about what it is that i'm
doing and then i can talk a little bit
on a more personal level about what we
found
we are at columbia university conducting
a two-year study we've just finished the
data collection part of that study in
fact in june
looking at about 9 000 children in new
york city in the boroughs of manhattan
and brooklyn
we have as well about 400 teachers who
are involved in the study so that we can
correlate responses between what
students tell us about what they're
doing and then what teachers tell us
about what children are doing in their
classrooms
we will spend the next two years looking
at that data but we have begun to look
at the data on a preliminary level so i
can talk a little bit about that but
more readily i think i want to focus on
what we found
in the schools in relation to what we
found and looking at the data because i
think that brings it home a lot more
significantly than just talking about
the data
leigh allen talked a lot about what he's
seen and what he's experienced
personally living in the community in
which he's lived
as he mentioned there
there's a war going on and it's going on
the streets every day it's happening
with young children and he spoke a lot
about children who were his age but in
fact it's happening with children who
are extremely young we work with a
population of students who are in grades
one through six
and we've experienced everything with
those children
i've gone into classrooms to conduct
data
with the children and
have
attempted to stop fights i've been
stabbed a couple of times with pencils
and pins and whatever other things kids
happen to have and i'm grateful that
they had pins and pencils as opposed to
knives and guns but it was scary
nonetheless to realize that
things are that out of control
teachers spend a lot of time yelling at
students because students bring so many
problems to school that they can't
concentrate on what they need to
concentrate on teachers are spending the
good majority of a 45 minute teaching
session of
yelling at students just to get order in
the classrooms the students are
very angry
they are very depressed
we have one school in particular where
the children don't even show up for
school until wednesday
they are very very poor
they come
sometimes from
projects they come sometimes from
homeless shelters they come sometimes
from the street
the
schools are in disarray
from the administration down
to the classrooms
we have
children being shot outside of schools
we had
a site that we were working in
um a young boy shot another young man on
his way to school
the oldest child with the gun was in
fifth grade the child that was shot was
in the third grade
it throws everything off in the school
setting we have
had the experience of one of our
principals in one of the sites we were
working with
her son was murdered
just before we began the study
the school was in disarray the principal
wasn't there for the first year of the
study
the school was total chaos
we have had every imaginable thing
happen with these kids when we look at
the data
we
then are able to see with facts with
statistics with hard evidence that what
we see in the classroom is really
playing itself out in a really crucial
way with children we have data that
indicates that children are extremely
aggressive and that everything that
happens to them from someone bumping
them slightly to dropping something in
front of them
they are attributing to hostile intent
they don't believe that anything's an
accident that you meant to hurt them
that you intended to hurt them and that
they intend to get revenge
and that's scary when you're talking
about first graders second graders and
third graders but that's what we're
finding we're finding that
it is particularly the case with
children of color latino kids in
particular black children in particular
it's happening with white children as
well just not in as great a proportion
with african-american children for
example
we find that they are the most
aggressive children in terms of how they
think about what's happening to them
white children and latino children are
aggressive as well
white children are less likely to act on
that aggression immediately
black children are much more likely to
act on their aggression they believe
that people are out to hurt them
and that they want to hurt them before
they themselves are hurt
they are depressed we've had measures of
depression but you can see it on the
children's face i mean we go around we
work with the children we sit with them
we ask them questions and they are
depressed they are very depressed you
ask them well
do you think everything is bad
and they say oh yes without hesitation
yes everything is bad is there anything
good
in your life
absolutely not they write in absolutely
it's not on our questionnaire
no everything we see is bad there's
nothing good happening to us
home's not good school is not good
community is not good and that's
frightening it's very frightening that
children at these ages are having those
experiences
what are we going to do to make the
difference for them i think lee allen
proposed some
solutions that will be crucial for us
but i think
in talking about
speaking to a group of lawyers i had to
think a lot about how could lawyers help
children
and coming from an agency as i do in
working with large populations of
students as a researcher i i'm thinking
on a somewhat larger scale and somewhat
more structured scale
and i wonder if
lawyers couldn't play really crucial
roles
in perhaps following legislation
for
um
at the federal level
on poor children
what's happening
on with poor children at the federal
level can we track that legislation
so that agencies like my own where we
concentrate specifically on poor
children who are six and younger
we can begin to make a difference at a
very early age because that's what's
needed
if we're finding what we're finding
first through sixth grade
you can believe that children
are experiencing things at much earlier
ages in fact myself and another person
are working on a chapter in a book and
we're talking about
the
early prevention that's needing to be
done and we're focusing on head start in
preschool populations
and we've already found just in the
research we've done on those populations
for the study that in fact preschool
children are in danger already not that
they're going to be in danger they are
in danger as of this date
um
so i think about legislation and the
ability to track legislation for
agencies like my own who are doing work
in other agencies um concentrating on
helping young children and poor children
in particular
i also think about lawyers being helpful
in lobbying for
children
lobbying for individual children
lobbying for organizations of children
how can we make a difference if we
really focus on children as the critical
element
of society
before
our policymakers
and finally i think
about
the representation that lawyers could
provide to organizations to large
organizations non-profit organizations
for example
they represent adults they represent
organizations and big businesses every
day
could that be those same skills be
transferred to nonprofit agencies for
representation on behalf of young
children
and i think prevention is the key so we
really want to focus on organizations
that are focusing on young children very
young children so that we can begin to
make the difference before children are
introduced to the system as criminals
because we know that if things continue
at the rate that they're going they will
in fact be introduced to the system as
criminals
and how can we stop that
before it gets too far along
the scary part is that too far along
is in elementary school these days
and so we need to be thinking about how
to make a difference for children as
early as head start in preschool
and that's really frightening as
the allen said
you're going to have a society
without youth because the youth is going
to be locked up if not
that's a scary picture
and i hope that we don't face it any
more than we've faced it already but
certainly something's going to have to
change if we hope to make a difference
[Applause]
jump right in i don't think i need to
stop here
my name is jack london
i
practice at a large law firm in san
francisco and a number of other cities
around the country it's morrison and
foster my firm
is
one of the 20 largest law firms in the
country and we've
for as long as i've been with the firm
and before had a very active
pro bono practice
but 10 years ago the chairman of our
firm
[Music]
asked us i was then as i am now the
chair of our
uh committee on pro bono work and he
asked us to think about whether it might
make sense
to adopt a theme
for the pro bono work and a focus for
pro bono work that we do and the theme
that he suggested was children in
poverty
and let me talk about what's in it for
us in that theme
he
wasn't is a he was a smart man and he
had a good idea
the theme of children in poverty is one
that allows anybody in a large
organization like a law firm
to do something
anybody with any amount of time any
level of skill
and to share with each other a common
purpose
and to share with each other every so
often a set of accomplishments and
recognize them as payoff on a project we
have undertaken
it turns out that children in poverty is
also a great
business developer
for
law firms and lawyers
you can do projects with your clients
i'll tell you about one in a minute it
really works
very well and it is something that uh if
if you take it on you will never regret
uh what we did
in order to develop this idea of a theme
about children in poverty
was a very rewarding and interesting
thing we went to experts
we went to
uh the children's defense fund and the
national center for youth law and people
at stanford and harvard the chief judge
of the los angeles
uh superior court in the family division
and to
other
public servants and child advocates and
we asked them all
a single question and it's a follow-up
our question was if you had
one of the largest law firms in the
country
and you were going to do something for
poor kids what would you do
and we took down the answers we got
about 50 very specific suggestions and
some general themes
and we put them together and tried to
make a menu an agenda if you will uh
trying to go out and and
in a very ethically permissible sense
solicit
uh
and and really i was uh struck when
faith was talking about how uh
she's still talking about some of the
same things we heard uh uh 10 years ago
uh the on the general themes of what
would be the most important things to do
for kids
uh we heard that serving as uh corporate
council that is that a big law firm that
most lawyers can do you can serve as
corporate counsel
for agencies that provide services to
kids
child care agencies have many problems
that arise and and you don't have to be
a specialist to help them as their
corporate council
uh providing incorporation services uh
work on regulatory issues which are
really quite extensive if you're in the
child care business as they as it should
be the case
if you're a big firm
you can do impact work we were told that
uh working as legislative council
was about the most important thing you
could do to affect the lives of many uh
many children
and then really as now the issues on
which that's essential start with things
like child support
there are billions of dollars over
probably plural billions of dollars
which kids are entitled to plural in
california alone certainly in the united
states which children are entitled to
and it's there and it's not being paid
and it should be
and the mechanisms are being improved by
legislation but that who's speaking for
kids
in uh congress
beyond that in
state legislatures and in the city
councils and boards of supervisors
someone should be there and saying to
these bodies here's what you could do
and here's what works somewhere else
that experience is available and you can
get it
now this has become the legislative
advocacy has become all the more
important because of
the the
setbacks that the congress has delivered
to federally funded legal services
agencies it is now restricted that is
agencies that serve
poor
people and receive federal money can't
do this job
not only can they not do it with federal
money they can't do it with any source
of funds
since
this year's restrictions have been
passed
someone has got to step up to the line
and do that work
these agencies were going to boards of
supervisors and their and their city
councils and saying here's what kids
need in your ordinances and now they
can't
so uh someone has got to step up to that
we were told ten years ago that's
something lawyers can do and it is
something lawyers can do
the the admission costs of learning the
area are not that great
uh the information is available there
are many who know this but not enough to
be out in the boards and city councils
and doing it and it is very important
impact litigation
if you're a big firm man can do it
that's another thing class actions are
now restricted
legal services recipients cannot do that
work in that way you can't represent a
class of people anymore if you receive
legal services corporation funding so
someone has to step up to that line as
well there are many class action cases
which are pending
and there are more that need to be
brought and
for the benefit of kids
having to do with child protective
services
and with
child custody practices with
these the standards of public
assistance with ch for children who have
health care problems are entitled to
public benefits
uh there is a list of areas and you can
connect and do this work that's what we
were told 10 years ago and it's even
more urgent now
since federal resources supporting legal
services
programs have been restricted
the the list
includes
representing individual kids in hearings
some of which are are technical and
require a great require really quite an
organized program for pro bono lawyers
to get involved with
some of which are more accessible
representing children and guardians and
and susan's going to talk about
abuse proceedings which really require a
great deal of skill
but but there are many proceedings in
which
pro bono lawyers can do kids some good
here's another one representing kids in
school suspension and expulsion cases
uh in many states this is an established
due process right
in some places it's not
in those places maybe impact litigation
to establish the right as a due process
matter is the thing that should be done
where it isn't right
these cases can be terrifically
rewarding we have taken on a case
in which uh in a high school in near
sacramento
there was toward the end of the year a
disruption in the school which led to a
big fight
which was labeled a riot
the police were called
and a hundred kids were cited
in the end the school in a very taking a
very hard stand on what they saw as
violence decided to suspend or expel 27
kids
a number of those kids had gotten
scholarships to college and were seniors
and they were going to lose those those
scholarships
uh there is an expel you can do a due
process hearing
uh they're rarely done with lawyers but
in this case we were able to get
involved with some other uh
through a child service agency and the
lawyers committee for civil rights in
san francisco we did 27 expulsion
hearings in the end only one boy was
expelled
we saved some scholarships that there is
really nothing more rewarding
than helping a kid in that kind of
situation
uh
there there's a long list of things that
can be done uh we have done things we
have taken this these uh this project on
as a theme we haven't said no to other
kinds of pro bono work in order to do
this but we have actively encouraged
this
impact work that we've done include the
school school desegregation case for
latino kids in
in san jose
we're involved now with the national
center for youth law in challenging in
enforcing a consent decree for the utah
child protective services agency because
they are not doing their job of
preventing violence to kids under their
supervision
uh there is a child
child support
system in in colorado that we've uh
helped the lawyer's committee challenge
big firms can do big cases and we should
but they're also the service cases the
the guardianship cases representing
child custody agencies the school
expulsion case i talked about but i'd
like to tell you about one particular
case which
combines both service and impact
uh
it's a case in which we represented
a child named alex
and his mother
alex was born uh with a severe
congenital problem
his lungs were born too small
his tongue was born too large and in the
wrong place
his uh
apparatus for breathing and for eating
and for drinking was was really very
very
troubled from birth
and there was no cure for this but there
was a treatment
he alex had and has a trach tube through
which he breathes
and he has a button in his stomach
through which she eats
and the problem for alex alex had uh
these severe health problems but he had
loving parents
and who cared for him a great deal and
and wanted to get him the best medical
care they could he alex was
alex's care was paid for by an hmo
and the hmo for the first four and a
half years of alex's life paid for the
nursing care at the at during the night
and uh eight hours during the day to
make sure that his trach tube didn't
clog because he would he would uh
asphyxiate
within minutes if something happened and
he needed full-time home nursing here
after four and a half years his hmo went
through a merger this is
probably most of us have had this
experience and then after the merger the
hmo decided that they needed to improve
on their cost containment
they sent a specialist to see
alex and she recommended some
changes in in the schedule for the nurse
and they the hmo considered that and
decided instead across the board for
alex and kids like him that
they really would not pay for home care
any longer
the youth law center got us involved in
the case and we were able to
get a preliminary injunction
and do discovery in the case
and
this is one of those cases that
litigators dream about because the
discovery turned up
recommendations from the specialists
which the higher up said well it would
cost too much and we don't care
the documents were so
hot the guns were smoking so clearly
that as soon as we were able to get the
discovery underway it became a
settlement case
and in the settlement we were able to
secure
alex's healthcare
for life
and some other relief for him but but
more important than that the hmo pledged
to change their policies for all kids on
home healthcare
and pledged for some monitoring
standards which are ongoing
um there are cases like that to be
brought every place anybody who wanted
to do a case like that you could be
involved between now and two weeks from
now helping some kid
and it's really rewarding
thank you
[Applause]
uh my name is susan cockfield and as uh
the judge mentioned i work in a firm and
i unlike the wonderful program at
jackson i'm the only person at my firm
who does
work on behalf of children i i so and i
i think that um
as probably was became clear i i do
individual cases i represent children in
foster care most of the time sometimes i
represent
kids in other proceedings like child
custody proceedings but
for the most part i'm in uh
abuse and neglect proceedings
representing children in those
proceedings and i i i think i want to go
back to what lee allen mentioned which
is that and against
how powerful one person can be in the
life of a child even though they're
presented with
the kind of problems that leon and faith
were talking about
and and and in particular i think it uh
it's so important for children in foster
care which is my my area because
those children are dealing not only with
all the problems that that we've all
talked about today but in addition are
dealing with the fact that they're not
in their own homes and not with their
own families and their families have the
problems of other poor families and
additional problems that make it so that
their children can't live
live at home and i i as jack mentioned
it's you know it's a specialized area
and i i wouldn't recommend anybody leap
into it uh without some
back you know learning about the field
and learning about the problems of
children
uh
poor children and poor children in
foster care but also wouldn't want
people to lose sight of the fact that
that you can learn about the the uh
the
system and can
make a difference in the life of a child
who is in foster care or any of the
other individual proceedings that that
that jack mentioned or that i'm sure you
all can imagine there are all sorts of
different contexts in which children
become involved in legal proceedings
and
as as lee allen said just one person
can make
a big difference i i was thinking as we
were talking about uh one of my clients
when i first came to florida
who had been in foster care well who had
been adopted taken out of a home where
her parents her biological parents were
drug abusers
and was uh was adopted with her sister
by a couple
and the uh
the
adoptive mother died of cancer and and
her this my client jones older sister
ended up going back into hrs custody
back into foster care and then when john
was nine she also ended up going back
into foster care adoptive fathers
surrendered her back to hrs
and she was in foster care then for the
next
five six years when i met her when she
was 15 and i started representing her
and uh she
was in the uh mental health facility
when i first met joan and then i would
say she was able to
get out of that mental health facility
and and
go into a group home situation and that
in that first stage of my representation
of her i was able to go to the mental
health facility and meet with the people
who were treating her and make sure that
her position and what she wanted to do
was was known and advocated for with
those people and then i was able to
work with her with as she was in the
group home with whatever problems came
up
when she was in the group home and then
um
i live in miami um
we had hurricane andrew in 92 and her
group home was destroyed and this is the
kind of thing i think that some people
not familiar with the system might think
well this is just all too overwhelming
and some this sounds like the life of
job which which you know it really is
but that at the same time i was able to
make a difference
and help joan in a way that that uh the
other people around here who weren't
just representing her weren't and so and
anyway her groupon got destroyed the
hurricane
and she wanted her group home parents
wanted her to come
live with them and and be
with them as a foster child and at that
time she was 16 years old and a lot of
times with older kids in particular you
know it's really uh the system
isn't very geared towards thinking in
terms of foster care an individual home
for an older child and uh
none of the people
on jones case were supportive of the
idea
from the the state agency or anywhere
else we're supportive of the idea of
joan going to live with these group home
parents uh
as a as a foster as a as a foster home
and in fact um we're proposing that
rather than going and live with these
parents these group home parents that
jones should go into a shelter
because these group owned parents
although they were licensed dense group
home parents weren't licensed foster
parents after that and then see now you
get down to the point where a lawyer
working on an individual child's case
can actually do something because i was
able to go to the judge and say judges
is stupid you you these people are
licensed group group home parents surely
they're
okay enough until they get licensed as
foster home parents for joan to live
with them and that's what the judge
ordered so you know against the backdrop
of enormous problems
problems really no one can do anything
about
uh as an individual you're still able to
do something that really
that really makes a difference and
really helps you know really help
somebody get a child like that like joan
who's had such a
tough life in the end get something at
least in the end when she was 16 she was
able to live with a family
and
which is what she wanted
and
that was
really it was really essential for her
to have somebody representing her
interest because otherwise it it would
not have happened
would not have happened that she would
she would get with what she wanted
and uh i think i tell those kind of
stories just to make it i don't know
whether it sounds like you know
uh
sounds inspiring the way i want to but i
want it to be but i think that the
important thing to remember is that
that that as lawyers as individual
lawyers no matter what your situation is
whether you have a firm that really has
a firm wise policy and
supports you or whether you in in terms
of devoting a huge number of resources
as jack's firm does or whether you have
a situation like mine where the firm is
very supportive of me but no one else
does that work you're still able to make
a difference and and
even if this even if it's one case one
child that's a that's a
uh
you know tremendously important thing to
do
and i don't i don't want to
underestimate the importance of of uh
learning about the system and getting
the support you can from the
organizations would you know which do
the work full-time and i think uh
although this is not something i do
personally i think it's very important
to uh try to get
not just pick up the work that's not
being being done by
legal services organizations now because
of what our legislatures of legislator
congressman chose chosen to do but also
work within our states and our private
uh private community organizations to
make sure to try to make sure that as
many full-time lawyers to do this work
as is funded as possible i i don't
i think it's uh
a pendulum situation now we're in a
situation where people
for whatever reason and and foolishly i
think as leon pointed out aren't
devoting public funding to these types
of organizations in the way they should
but that doesn't mean i don't think that
we can't
work towards
getting funding from other sources and
supporting the organizations as lawyers
that which do this work in addition to
doing whatever pro bono work we can we
can do
thank you susan
[Applause]
what we see in the presentation from the
panelists this morning is that there are
real problems out there but there are
many ways in which lawyers can relate to
these issues the problems are monumental
they get larger and larger all the time
but the opportunities for public service
particularly given the skills
that we as lawyers bring
um
to the world um given what we've learned
and how hard we've worked there are many
ways in which we can feel good about our
profession and
can give the public a sense of
our commitment to public service and to
our communities by involving on an
individual basis on a firm basis or with
other lawyers from other firms or with
bar associations and groups of bar
associations or groups within the bar um
we can embark involve ourselves in the
individual lives of children which i
think is critical but also in the
community's response
to our communities children
this is a good opportunity we've seen
that the tension there is between what's
out there and what lawyers can do this
is a good opportunity for you to ask
questions make comments for the
panelists if they want to jump into to
respond to something some other
panelists may have said
give us about i want you to raise your
hand simply because there's a boom mic
out there and i want c-span to be able
to get to you um so they can make sure
they can hear you
yeah
right
just
there you go
uh i i was interested faith in your uh
discussion or observations about very
young kids and how they sound
as if they're in distress
they feel threatened and anxious
when when
one of our kids feels anxious or
distressed we go to them we stay with
them we talk to them and comfort them
that felt to me like a way that
we can understand the different types of
things that lawyers can do for kids
very often it feels overwhelming whether
it's a health care crisis taking on an
insurance company or a homicide
and yet for each of those experiences
there's just this child
um
what kind of experiences have you folks
had in you know or in meeting folks or
in yourselves walking along with kids so
that you in a sense relieve their their
personal anxiety and at the same time
corrected some of their problems
i think
what
what you do is first you have to contend
with teachers issues
around dominance in their classrooms and
that's a very big problem teachers are
very territorial because they have no
power within the school structure and so
you have to get past all the politics
first there's a lot of issues between
teachers and administrators that we had
to overcome before we could even get to
the children and that's where the focus
is you really want to concentrate on the
children we had to sometimes ask
teachers we realize it's your classroom
can we please for 45 minutes just take
over
because the teachers were yelling at the
kids the kids were yelling at each other
they were throwing things across the
room at each other they were calling
each other names and you just have to
wait a second when you see certain kids
who sit in the classroom you know that
they are just so depressed they're sad
they're crying because they obviously
are not connected with the rest of the
kids in the classroom and those are the
kids that you focus on you go around the
classroom and you're asking all the the
questions of the kids the same but you
you come back to the kids who clearly
need your attention you sit with them
and you help them complete the
questionnaire you ask them questions
along the way and say it's okay whatever
you think it's all right
and let them know that they have an
opinion kids don't believe that what
they think is important so if they look
sad
they would love for you to pat them on
the back or say are you okay but they
don't expect it because they don't get
it at school they can't teachers
attention is so many other places
um
you you want to believe that the focus
is really on educating the children
while they're in the classroom but so
much of teachers attention is diverted
to controlling
the couple of kids or the few kids in
the classroom who are just taking
their schedule off course and so the
children who
don't have a voice because they're
saddened by whatever is going on at home
or whatever they saw on the way to
school or however they're being treated
in the classroom are sitting there and
they have clear signs of distress and we
just tend to spend more time with those
kids we talk to them more we see them in
the hall during their breaks and we say
hi to them um and it's that's the stuff
that they want i mean they said can you
please come back again
you just you don't even have to ask a
question you can ask us more questions
just come back and that's what we do
when we're in a school for anything
we'll just go back into the classroom
sick and we spend a few seconds with the
kids just to say hi let them know that
you know we wanted to see them again or
if they're at lunch we'll go and sit and
have lunch with them um
and that's what the children need it's
hard to be able to give them what we'd
like to be able to give them i think
school officials and administrators
think of researchers as bad people and
we had to let them know we have children
too and we're human and we're really
normal people honestly
we just do this as a profession and then
we go home at night
and we had normal lives and we really
had to convince people that we were we
were not researchers
24 hours a day that we really were human
people most of our lives and that we
just did this as a profession but that
we really did have a very strong
interest in being able to help children
process what they're going through from
day to day and we were able to do that
much more effectively in some schools
and others depending on the dynamics of
the school
yes the gentleman here in the back
that's a question for jack london um
about the um
your pro bono program the atmosphere
inside your firm what are the
opportunities for new associates are
they encouraged to uh participate are
they given enough time to uh
to get involved in in some of the cases
that you were talking about
actually
the secret is new associates drive the
program
people come out of law school
remembering why they went to law school
and
they
the key to a strong pro bono program is
to let them
and then the habits are formed
it's very difficult to introduce
somebody to the habit of doing pro bono
work regularly when they're five or
eight years into the practice before
they start
so
it is essential
to a good and a strong pro bono program
that you give assurance to the beginning
uh associates that it's okay
and if you do that and you keep those
people for long enough so that they're
here on panels talking to you because
that's how i started
uh you
you will have a strong program you do
need to have uh there's and there's lots
of learning about how to have a strong
pro bono program
it's best to have formal policies
it's best to have a structure it's best
that the assurance is that it's okay
both be written
and that somebody be responsible for
them
you need to have partner involvement
in in every case at some level
the center for pro bono and the law firm
project of the aba have compiled a great
deal of information about
uh policies that that work
and uh the aba really has done a a good
deal on this and it's it's readily
available to you
okay tonight actually i i'd like to
follow up on that comment also and say
that that i think firms i was lucky to
run into a firm that when i was moving
from a place like lawyers for children
where i started which is a non-profit
legal services type organization to
private practice
i would you know i was lucky to find a
firm which didn't immediately think of
me as being unsuited to corporate
litigation simply because i i had
started off my careers in the legal
services public interest
area and i think that one thing that
firms can do is is
you know make sure they don't uh they
they consider people with those
backgrounds because i i
i don't know how many people here today
are litigators but the litigators are
pretty much litigators and you don't
have to to necessarily pigeonhole people
and say well if they're in public
interest they're not appropriate for
um you know private law firm and if
there was that kind of
i i mean i'm not i don't have i i have
no empirical evidence to suggest that
people aren't that flexible but i have
the sense that they're not so i i think
they that that would help too if you
have people in your firm who have worked
in the public
public service um
legal services area then they can
and they're there's
they can be a source of information and
and help to other people in the firm who
want to do pro bono and and they can
continue their pro bono work in the
private setting i think that would be a
real healthy good development can i talk
just for one more minute about about
your question because
i haven't talked about something
important that is what's in it for the
firm in doing pro bono work and in
letting their young associates all the
way up do it
our firm competes with other firms who
pay the same amount of money we all pay
a great deal of money to compete for the
best legal talent but we pay the same
and our offices are nice and so are
theirs and and what's the difference
what's our selling point one selling
point that we have is that we let
lawyers
take the steering wheel of this great
big truck and aim it at something and
run it over
that is you can you can decide you want
to do a take on a pro bono project and
the firm will support you in doing it
it's like a a car company that could
hire engineers by saying
we'll let you use the assembly line to
design a beautiful car
what kind of engineers do you hire when
you hire on that basis engineers who
love cars and who build great cars and i
think there is empirical support for
saying
the lawyers who love pro bono work and
love to do the work just for what can be
done with the law
tend in the long run to be very valuable
lawyers to have i think it's a
long-range recruiting advantage and it's
an economic value to a firm outweighs
all the costs
in the back
a narrow question for mr london and a
question for the group
as far as a pro bono and the associates
are they given any credit for their
hours or are they still required to get
the 2 000 2100 hours a year
and then for the group
there's a lot we've heard about lawyers
being able to help in individual cases
for individual children and uh maybe in
some impact litigation but
what about the 15 hours 16 hours a day
lee allen discussed that they're not in
school and they're on the streets what
can we as lawyers
we as society i guess is even a better
question do to help the children out in
that in that part of their lives
to answer your question uh every uh pro
bono hour counts the same as a billable
hour
for the basic expectation we've just
started giving a bonus for high hours
and pro bono always count for that bonus
too
i'd like to respond to your your
question for the group i think there are
a number of things that lawyers can do
i i sincerely believe that lawyers
for for children are this
this abstract group of people i mean
it's sort of like liam said i mean he
thought you guys were a group of people
who supported the habit of drinking
um and i think children don't understand
what lawyers do
and when they are old enough to
understand that lawyers have some
connection with the criminal justice
system they then view you as bad people
sort of like researchers or good people
because you get them all you right if
you get the boss but they only assume
that you only you get rich people off
most of the kids that we see in the
inner city are far from wealthy and they
can't imagine what wealthy feels like
although they fantasize about how it
would be if they were
but i think if you were able to to meet
children where they are
be mentors to them be educated to them
let them know
what it is that a lawyer does
before they're introduced to the system
as a criminal because they're being
introduced at such young ages these days
um to
to crime
witnesses of crime perpetrators of crime
meet them where they are meet them in
their community because that's where
they're hanging out
they're on the corner they're hanging
with their buddies
and they're cursing up the storm
it's amazing the things that come
you know come out of the children's
mouth
at really young ages and sometimes i
hear them curse and i turn around others
man my parents would have had a heart
attack
but their parents aren't around
so if if you're able as an attorney to
meet children where they are and to
introduce them to what you do
then they are beginning then at much
earlier ages to understand
that
you are people that you can help them
that you can introduce them to
to life
without it having to look so dismal
at such an early age
but i think being able to meet them
where they are would be really helpful
because a lot of times they don't see a
way out of where they are so if you
don't go to them
they're only going to come to you by the
system there's an old idea that that
some
businesses have done that you don't have
to be a law firm to do this and that's
adopting a school
uh we've got an adopt-a-school program
uh with a uh an elementary school
in san francisco
and this was
i alluded to this earlier we do this
with a client bank of bank of america
uh the bank supplies vans that pick uh
our uh people up
uh four times a day and uh people at
morrison and the bank of america
are teacher aides on a regular scheduled
basis at the school
our library does the cataloging of their
library we all publish their newspaper
uh when they do
their
holiday concerts they come and sing for
us and we go to them and
and uh
put on
uh trials with the kids or as the
lawyers
uh and uh our the chairman of our firm
who gave us this big idea uh used to go
every week and read stories to the kids
and get to know them and and uh it can
be a really rewarding thing and it and
everybody can do it yeah do you want to
come in and uh everyone's in the
comments with uh my
my answers so that i'm just going to sit
back and wait for the next question
i want to ask kathryn ross who's
the chair of the steering committee on
the unmet legal needs of children to
respond to that question because i think
there may be some ideas she has about
her experience and working on behalf of
aba that might be helpful to all of us
thanks clint
one thing that was very gratifying was
that so many of the ideas that came up
on this panel are actually related to
her exactly the same as the ideas in our
new booklet make a difference 25
projects for lawyers and for each
project we've given you resources of
groups that have done the program can
provide you with materials and ideas
about how to set it up we can also help
you to help to connect with people in
your own community or to get further
resources uh which is ought to say that
i don't immodestly that great minds
think alike but i think we're all moving
in the same direction um certainly it's
very important for
law firms to recognize this work and
it's something that's important not just
for the goodwill that it and the
recruiting that it creates for firms as
jack pointed out and i started out doing
a lot of impact mitigation at a large
firm myself
and it really gets the fire in your
belly going so it makes you into a
first class litigator as well
but
it
enhances the image of our profession and
it reminds us as lawyers as well as
reminding non-lawyers in the country
about what justice is all about
and
justice is about making sure that
everybody gets a shock that everybody's
needs are met and you achieve that not
just through laws that are sitting on
the books
but by enforcing laws
by making new laws
through impact litigation through
representing individual children and
when lawyers do things with the children
in the 14 hours that they're out of
school like reading to them
like mentoring
whether it's as a lawyer or something
you do through your religious
affiliation or your community you learn
about the social problems
that children face in the allen's
community and in other communities
and inevitably
if you're a good person and a good
lawyer that will give you a lot of your
own ideas about how to respond to the
needs that you're discovering and if you
have ideas like that that we haven't
been publicizing we would love to hear
from you thank you all for coming and i
hope you come back this afternoon yeah
one other thing i would mention here
we're not we still have a few minutes is
that
one we have a judge in atlanta for
example who for 15 years has been the
troop leader for a boy scout troop in a
public housing project
you don't have to do legal work you can
simply be yourself and meet kids where
they are
um and help to meet those needs one
little announcement with regard to
specifically pro bono programs for
children
the section litigation task force on
children on monday
the fifth tomorrow between two and five
will be presenting um a workshop on how
to start a program program for those of
you in firms or
lawyers here who might want to
individually work on that that's at the
buena vista hotel in the cloister north
room
from two to five the section of
litigation tomorrow monday august 5th
any other
questions yes in the back
i want to try to be delicate with this
but i feel like there's this lumbering
giant behind us that's fighting and
we're still sort of punching at the
shadow a little bit
dr samples one of your comments was
about the need for lawyers to legislate
and you're talking in a week where we
just saw the congress bipartisan
you know congress both sides knocking
off the mere
um safety net the remnants of the safety
net so i think we need to take the
gloves off a little bit and turn around
and really punch the giant and you know
i love all these
i really don't have anything against all
the programs that have lawyers out
mentoring and taking on schools and i
think there's a lot of truth to what you
say about maybe that will get them
really to understand what the real
problems are but i think it's ironic
that we talk about associates doing work
and we when we really talk about problem
solving for rich clients and for
powerful clients we talk about major
league partners coming in and saying i'm
going to kick ass and take names and
make deals with power i think that's
great idea i i think that's really
terrific excuse me but it really is
unfair to the kids out there who are
living these lives to ignore them and
pretend we're fighting the revolution
we've got to recognize excuse me excuse
me no i i just no no i'm sorry i've
worked too hard on this panel i've seen
too many people out there doing good
things one on one for anybody to pretend
that that isn't good enough i didn't say
it excuse me i'm going to finish well i
was no no no
see i think it's real it's it is very
important for people to do both
i didn't
work no but you you dismissed it you
said you think we're not all these
little programs that's your language you
got to watch that language
these kids are out there they need us
and they need us one-on-one as well as
dealing with the legislature it's not
just about punching the giant it is
about taking you yourself who you are
and going out there and touching the
life of a child which i do every day and
i don't think that's the point i'm
making i think what i'm making
though the point i made is that we're
talking about a part of it
lawyers also do a lot of punching the
giant
and
important well-paid lawyers do it as
well as young lawyers who are starting
out and learning the american bar
association fought very very hard to
protect the entitlement of children to
welfare it has fought very very hard to
keep the children of immigrants eligible
for benefits we have policies that
many of the aba committees develop and
bring to our governing body and based on
those policies as an association we
lobby very very hard for children and
many of the leading members of the bar
join in those efforts as witnesses
calling
contacting congressmen and senators who
they know from their communities and all
of that is equally important work
you know let me just finish my point
because i'm not attacking the american
bar association my point is that there's
a lot that lawyers do and they do it
well and in addition to being out on the
street with kids which i do every day
i've represented some kids for 12 years
i know the kids and i see people out
there doing it i've also seen a lot of
programs that that
allow lawyers not to address the other
real problems and the big problems but
people have to do what they can do
there's no need to be defensive about it
no but you shouldn't condemn any of it
is what i'm getting at you keep
dismissing something if it isn't
important i think you're reading
something into my point that's not there
then maybe i listen to it that's all
good work there's nothing wrong with
that work then why point is missing it
i just said it's good work it is good
work there's nothing stop there
okay now the bigger point that i want to
make which you seem to want to ignore is
that there's other work that lawyers do
and should other lawyers are to do that
otherwise for example when you talk
about class actions which can really be
excellent you're lassoing one of the
fingers of the giant and trying to pull
it around and i'm saying there is if you
if you calculate the hours in the law
firms i think the associates are doing
most of the pro bono hours it'd be nice
to see the lawyers who've been partners
for a while out there i refuse to
condemn anybody i want people to do
whatever they can do whenever they can
do it wherever they can do it
whether they're big-time lawyers or
small-time lawyers new or old my point
is no place my point isn't criticizing
the associates
there's no there's no criticism there
thanks
yes
thank you right here up front
i'd like to make a comment i just
finished my first year of law school at
the university of miami and i spent my
first summer at miami's first in-house
legal clinic which represents children
in foster care mostly older children
teenagers and sort of in between i think
what a lot of what
ms cockfield does and what mr london's
firm does um is what we have done which
was a sort of a relentless barrage
against hrs against one particular issue
which is the provision of independent
living services to prepare children for
the transition the time when they turn
18 and the state says that's it you're
on your own despite what we've done to
you in your in or not done for you in
your troubled past and as a result of
our work already and it's it's all been
to this point work on behalf of
individual clients we've been able to
cause a major shakeup in the juvenile
dependency court both from the
standpoint of the judges who are now
looking for this issue pulling all of
the files of teenagers who are about to
be released from state care and also
within hrs itself which is now applied
for a grant to get six new full-time
case workers to deal with this issue so
i don't think that the impact
litigation and the individual caseworker
mutually exclusive the second comment
that i'd like to make is that i think
that um
from what i've seen
so far in my limited experience with the
legal world is that
sometimes lawyers may think that
that helping children and legal work are
sort of mutually exclusive and i i just
remember one client that i had where i
was explaining to him about a program
that he wanted to participate in a
program provided by the state and one of
the
through the department of hrs they had
imposed a requirement a grades
requirement that did not exist in the
statutory language authorizing the
program and
i i wanted to be able to say to this kid
look pull your grades up it's going to
help you out
if it's almost in the parenting role and
as a lawyer there was a way to do that
and the way to do that was to say look
we're here to fight for you we're here
as your lawyer we're here as your
advocate but it's a lot easier not have
to not to have to fight fights if you
don't have to fight and if you can pull
your grades up we're going to save
ourselves a lot of trouble down the road
but if you don't pull your grades up
we'll be there for you but let's try to
save the fight there's more that you can
do other than just
being a strict legal advocate within the
courtroom it goes it goes beyond that
and so
those are the couple ideas that i
thought
there's a is there a question over here
the young woman here and then
i appreciate the young woman part
uh i want to first of all commend the
aba for having the children's day
overall picture i um i'm a natural
resources lawyer but my passion is
children's advocacy and this panel has
been very informative i have a specific
question of leanne liaon which is uh
what is the most
important thing that happened in your
life four years ago that turned you
around from going to the gang
scene and being here with us today
artfully telling us
about your life
well four years ago
we had a program in our school like a
mentoring program called the nodal
express
and see i didn't take the program very
serious and i was just like well i'm
gonna do what i want anyway it's not too
much because you know every school has
programs like that that like there for
like the remaining six weeks of the
school and you just go and they just
have it there but around the program you
know you talk you know like you said
you're rowdy
and they and they demanded uh you know
we respected them and they respected us
so the uh
the mentor was telling me uh you know to
shut up you know and i was laughing uh
if you ever hear me laugh i mean i laugh
like a chipmunk like stop laughing like
a chipmunk you know
like uh well i stood up in front of the
cloud and said well if you address me of
my name which lee allen jones
that you know maybe you will get some
cooperation out of me and all that was
that
every you know most teachers we ain't
got young teachers in because the school
was going through some reform and they
brought young teachers in and they
didn't really know how to handle you
know teaching you know they know how to
do it in the classroom with a book but
yet when they were
with real students and with real
situations they didn't know how to
handle it when the person came to me
direct and was uh no real with me and i
and it just brought something out of me
and they showed me a different way they
said well
we can show you people
that have went that way and this is what
they're doing we can show you people
that we've done then for it look what
they're doing and i just wanted to be
to be happy i mean i just want to do
something i like being different and
that program brought the difference out
of me and that's what i'm doing now
well
yeah other questions i believe
[Music]
i had another question for leigh allen
and that is listening to what people
have talked about here about what jack
was saying about way lawyers can help
and some of the other people i wondered
what you're hearing from kids and
grown-ups in your community about things
that can be done things like no dope
express or other other ways in which
people can help out and
change things one thing that sounds
brought up that i was thinking of that i
didn't get out was that uh the mentoring
part i mean let's take law out of the
picture for us one second
take part in the picture for one second
and deal with these kids or mutually
a love not law not you know uh
university of miami not wherever you
graduated from a cumula but one-on-one
let's knock all that out and what you
have to show them
in life spectrum and if you can do that
and then law can play it plays a key
role but yeah if you come if kids are
real now they don't phony people
don't last long from where i'm from i
mean if you're a phony person you're
spotted outright
and
if you come with kids and well you know
i'm just doing this for pro bono hours
or whatever it shows
you have to do it for love and respect
and out of kind heartedness and you know
not you know because i want to get 200
whatever pro bono owls you can get for
your firm but on you know mutual love
respect and out of kind-heartedness
yeah uh one last question
um i wanted to follow up in a miss
cockfield and what miss when mr london
was
introducing her and what she did
he made it sound like it was some sort
of brain surgery and that uh just
because you're in a in a in maybe a
business setting that you can't
represent children in wealth child
welfare cases i i am and i represent
human services in a rural area in west
texas and we are desperate for good
advice and i think a good deadline
you don't have to know the law
you you can read the family code there's
two chapters that deal with it in texas
and you can you can understand it pretty
well what they need are people who will
come and read our cases read our case
files meet the children and come to
court and believe it or not usually
percent of our lotters who are paid for
their work do not do that
and i believe if you can do those three
things you can represent these children
very well and i think that more
more
more people need to do that and not be
afraid of it because i think the people
who are really afraid of it are the
people that are really thinking about it
and would do a good job in those cases
so thank you
thank you very much
i want to thank all of our panelists uh
susan cockfield um jack london faith
samples and especially lee allen jones
again i want to remind you that the
litigation section the judicial
administration division and the
commission on homelessness and poverty
all co-sponsored children's day
i want to thank
c-span
you do
uh nope you very much for coming and
participating this has been a really
exciting day and a wonderful program
thank you very much
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
hi buddy
right
this week on america and the courts
supreme court justice clarence thomas he
visits with students at south